[Music]
[Music] 1:08 point one miles an hour
ET 13-3 strictly street condition
the word is out in the world of wheels and
the word is Barracuda 70 Barracuda all-new
and the hottest thing on wheels clean tough
lines with the long hood short deck styling
that makes a sporty car this one is Hemi
Cuda with a dazzling 426 engine and just
wait till the kids see this shaker
hood the air intake comes right up
through the hood the engine is soft
mounted so it shapes as the car idles
hood lock pins for the sports car look and
other sports car touches like road wheels racing
mirrors big white lettered f70 tires optional
elastomeric bumpers practically indestructible
yes when the bench racing starts the talk
this year is Barracuda [Music] and here's
more exciting news for 1970 this is Barracudas
gran coupe of brand-new high style barracuda
and
Barracuda brand coupe new plush way
to go in the specialty car feet sport
car styling front and rear this is
real luxury in a sporty car [Music]
genuine leather trim and overhead
is a unique roof-mounted consulate
that tells you barracuda or 70
muscular styling mind-blowing
performance anyone with gasoline in
his veins will be awestruck [Music]